this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you everybody for coming it's
really nice to be here I'm gonna start
out because I'd last time I gave a talk
recently I forgot to do this or we're
promoting our new center for parasitic
and carnivorous plants somehow we have
amassed pretty large number people
working on this on these sort of extreme
strange lifestyle plants and so we're
trying to get some momentum and do some
integrative work in these sort of odd
systems and I'll I'll touch on some
parasitic plant that we're working on in
the middle of the talk so anyways it's
nice to be here
we're working a lot and local adaptation
and that's a theme that runs throughout
what I'm going to present today the
research can going to present there are
other topics involved but local
adaptation is kind of a central theme
and I'm gonna try to rely on that to
give a sort of broad intro here and I've
started developing a new introduction to
my talk in the last few days because
there's a new sort of way and it's not
new really but I just wanted to present
a certain side to the local adaptation
problem that we're thinking about and so
I want to start by talking about
trade-offs and the idea that there is no
such thing as a free lunch or that the
trade-offs are a Bic witness I really
like this this is sort of an aphorism
that's used a lot in economics but it
really sticks in the back of my mind and
I consider myself at heart an
evolutionary colleges although we do
genetics and physiology as well but I
really sort of often am inspired by the
really close connections between ecology
and economics of course that goes back a
long time so the roots of those words
but also the the no free lunch thing
really sticks in my mind a lot and the
origin of this phrase I think it's kind
of neat so from the 19th century bars
and saloons had this practice of
advertising a free lunch to get people
to come in and drink in the middle of
the day but you know so this guy goes in
and does that of course but there's
obviously embedded in that clearly
potential downside to that you know
getting drunk in the middle of the day
and so I think that that that sort of is
a nice way to sort of set the framework
for thinking about changes or things
that might benefit plants or organisms
certain ways but may limit them and
others so I want to move a little bit
more in this on this theme of the
trade-offs and talk briefly about this
sort of idea
there there may be constraints to our
ability to improve our performance we
think about multiple multiple dimensions
of procurements so the idea of a Pareto
front is one that's often used and when
talking about this kind of work and
there's the idea is that a Pareto front
is sort of the maximum possible
performance you can have in multiple
dimensions so that if you move to a
better state in one dimension you're
necessarily reducing your performance in
another dimension now you may think for
where you're sitting in your given
system and the given axes performance or
the given dimensions that you're
thinking about you may think that you're
perhaps sitting pretty far from that
front you can perhaps improve in
multiple dimensions that you care about
at the same time but I'd like to suggest
that there are many dimensions to
performance many environmental contexts
that lead to trade-offs and that's one
of the reasons why we see such
biodiversity that we do now put this now
in the context of local adaptation and
the idea with local adaptation is that
there is a trade-off in Fitness across
environmental gradients so the different
genotypes have highest relative fitness
depending on where you are along an
environmental gradient just as an
example we have some continuous
environmental gradient and you do two
different common gardens in assert
priciple transplant experiment let's say
with these trees this red genotype
that's from the red environment has
higher Fitness in that environment and
that switches when you get to the other
end of the environmental gradient this
is a fitness trade-off which defines
local adaptation if you sort of want to
plot that out and on this in this
concept of the the Pareto front if you
think that this genotype has some
optimized performance for this
environment a where it's found and been
presumably evolving for some period of
time if you move it to the environment
that B is from its performance
necessarily is reduced and vice-versa so
this is just sort of a general
conceptual framework for local
adaptation and we're now going to sort
of I'm gonna visit start thinking about
some specific questions that we have
about local adaptation big-picture
questions that motivate us that we want
to know about it are the following one
is how important is local adaptation
it's fairly straightforward to
characterize genetic diversity among
populations either by sequencing things
or by measuring things in controlled and
by our common environments but but how
much of that diversity that we see is
because of local adaptation versus
limited gene flow and genetic drift
which can also
explain differences among populations
and why does this differ from systems a
system or through time perhaps second
major area of inquiry is what our
underlying types of genetic mechanisms
or physiological mechanisms involved in
the local adaptation and then thirdly
are there potential applications of
learning about local adaptation and how
it happens is there perhaps applied
biology benefits to this
so these major topics sort of frame the
three sections of the talk and for each
of these sections I sort of have a
vignette in a different system three
different systems that I'll go through
today so the first one in rice Asian
rice I'm going to be asking what's
behind the genetic differences we see
among populations and specifically
landraces
so these are sort of traditionally
adapted varieties of these crops I'll
come back to that concept in a moment
secondly in sorghum we're going to think
about finding the genetic basis of local
adaptation and seeing if that can tell
us something about how local adaptation
happens in in sorghum landraces
and then thirdly in the model system a
rabbit abscess I'm going to think about
how we may be able to apply some of our
knowledge about the genetic basis of
local adaptation okay so first starting
out on this question of how important is
local adaptation or versus other factors
that might explain some of the
differences we see among populations I
want to start out by making the case
that landraces of major crops are really
nice systems for evolutionary genetics
and evolutionary ecology and and that's
because we have huge collections of
diversity already existing in germ plasm
banks and they're are from really
broadly distributed environments so
these are just the two thousand sorghum
land races that we've done you tighten
by sequencing on not in my lab but with
collaborators and you can see they
really span a range of precipitation
environments these colors are showing
your growing season length you can see
something similar with the 1400 rice
landraces that we're working with here
they're from a pretty broad range of
environments so
the idea with the land race is that it's
a traditional variety rooted in the
location at least we think these things
are locally adapted to a certain degree
which means that in these immense
collections of land races we have
alleles and traits that are adapted to
specific environments and so that's
patek perhaps a really useful resource
for applied reasons as well but also
from the perspective of just learning
about how selection and other
evolutionary forces generate diversity
or influence diversity I think these are
really nice systems yes okay so getting
back to rice which is the main system
that we talked about in the first part
of this talk I want to think about four
sort of categories of covariant or
explanatory factor that might be
responsible for some of the genetic
differences we see among land races now
each one of these could correspond to at
heart a process that is that is limited
gene flow or that is local adaptation
and differential selection so first
geographic isolation now I think this is
probably mostly going to correspond to
patterns of gene flow but land races
that are found in different places will
diverge simply because of genetic drift
and limited gene flow and we may be able
to model that based on Geographic
distance or perhaps something a little
bit more sophisticated which is an
estimate of travel time at the same time
though because environments are
spatially Auto correlated meaning that
environments are similar nearby in space
and as you move farther you're more
likely to move to a new environment this
could also correspond to changes in
selection and then abiotic conditions
we're going to consider so we know that
there is some role in abiotic gradients
in selecting for different genotypes in
space in Raceland races another major
broadly distributed plants and we're
going to include a number of abiotic
conditions in this analysis as well and
now at the same time also we know this
broad region of traditional rice
cultivation also has an immense human
cultural diversity and so it could be
that for example groups that speak
similar languages are more likely to
share seeds with each other so the gene
flow may be greater with within language
groups than among or
alternatively there may be different
cultural preferences that select for
different types of you know that's like
four different genotypes in between
these different groups so we're gonna
consider these as well and then a single
locus mutation that we're gonna consider
is the the waxey locus so this is the
mutation that is responsible for
creating gelatinous rice thinking about
and there's reasons to think that
there's limited gene flow between sticky
and non sticky varieties and also
perhaps selection for additional traits
that might interact with the sticky non
sticky phenotype so each of these could
correspond to something that predicts
patterns of gene flow or selection
mostly I'm going to spend some time
talking by setting these a little bit
more so it give you some background and
a sort of set up hypothesis for the
diversity of rice within traditional
varieties of rice that we have in our
collections at least and that have
sequenced there are two main varieties
japonica and indica japonica was the one
that was domesticated earlier in the
Yangtze Valley and was had already
started to spread by 3,000 BC into
Southeast Asia 2000 BC into the
Northeast Asia
compare that with in so there's a lot
going on here I'm just gonna try to
focus on the important parts about 200
2500 BC what's what what's referred to
here is proto indica or one of the main
ancestors of indica was still being just
a mess being grown just in northern
Indian subcontinent
so the backdrop here is that japonica
domesticated here spread first and then
much later
indica spread and now they're sort of
both broadly cultivated across this
region so perhaps given that perhaps
given the japonica spread earlier
there's been a greater time to
accumulate genetic divergence between
populations either due to a longer
period of genetic drift in isolation or
a longer period of adaptation to local
conditions
now thinking about limited gene flow we
want to try to be a little bit more
sophisticated than just estimating the
patterns of gene flow based on
geographic distance between locations so
one way we might do that is try to
approximate the ways in which the seed
moved about the landscape which would be
sort of low technology mechanisms of
human movement and so we've done this in
collaboration with MS Layton as a
computational archaeologist and we're
using what's sort of a simple standard
function for estimating how fast people
hike across the landscape depending on
the slope and then also a fairly low
speed of moving over the ocean which is
meant to sort of approximate historical
traditional sailboats and then we can
take our full landscape of the entire
East Asia and estimate how much it costs
or how easy it is to move from place to
place and then for any given two points
of interest we can calculate at least
cost path so in this case these green
cells these are higher cost the least
cost path from A to B skirts those green
cells here's an example of the least
cost path separating two of our
landraces rather than the real
Geographic distance representing likely
gene flow between these two people would
probably have skirted the Himalayas
because both of these are low elevation
sites so the real least cost path and
the likely distance may be better
estimated by something like this so
we're gonna apply these this this method
to the broad diversity of land races
that we have here well give you some
background on the data and the set up of
this project so this is a close
collaboration with the Pergamon lab at
NYU and the data we're working with are
largely from the rice three thousand
genomes project so about 1,200 of the
land races that we use are from that and
then fergan in lab sequence almost two
hundred more rice land races so this is
the broad distribution this is the
distribution of the 1,400 land races and
then if you look at an ordination of the
about 10 million snips that we have from
those you can see that the the two main
varieties indica and japonic are clearly
distinguished on this first axis and
this is a pretty deep split this
explains about 1/3 of that total snip
variation so we're just going to analyze
two separately the indica and japonica
so let's look at how geographic distance
or travel time explained genetic
isolation so for japonica first we found
that least-cost travel time is favored
now when I do this and these two plots
here I'm showing you what I calling
Island japonica and then continental
japonica and I'm separating these out
because we think the mechanisms of
movement might have been different
between them our error and our bias in
this predictive model may have been
different between these two Bradlee
different regions that's why I've split
the two up you can see with continental
continental japonica a fairly clean at
least lower bound on genetic divergence
that's increasing with our estimated
travel time and in both cases the this
travel time is fitting the model better
than Geographic distance this is the
island japonica it doesn't fit as well
and I've also sort of separated out here
comparisons between land races that are
either in the same genetic luster or in
different ones because there's two sort
of Maine japonica clusters genetic
lustres on the islands so in this case
here's an example of a land race where
our pair of land races where travel time
was a better predictor of isolation than
Geographic distance so you can see this
Geographic distance was maybe a little
ambitious going over these two mountain
ranges whereas it was sort of easier to
sort of stick to the coast estimated
from our predictive model this is this
is for japonica japonica is the is
indeed the more genetically structured
of the two the average FST among nine
clusters was about two point four six
whereas for indica it's only point two
four and we can see with indica actually
four indica the model selection favors
Geographic distance as a measure of
isolation so this is again a measure of
distance instead of travel time it's
actual kilometers and then on the y axis
again as genetic divergence between
pairs of land races so overall you can
see the genetic divergence doesn't get
as high for indica and these
relationships are also a bit weaker they
are positive though so there is still
evidence that there's limited gene flow
across space but it's weaker for indica
so perhaps one way to interpret this is
that hypothesis that I sort of set up
before which is that if japonica spread
earlier and
perhaps was evolving and genetic drift
was or local adaptation was occurring in
all these different places especially
when perhaps human technology of
movement was lower and there may have
been longer period of time for the
accumulation of these divergences the
virgin's between land races of japonica
and indica which spread more recently so
perhaps that's why we're better able to
predict genetic divergence with this
movement model it could be that human
movement technology changed a bit since
a spirit of japonica such that we
weren't modeling it as well for indica
okay so I'm gonna think again about
these other factors now so we looked at
this issue of whether we might be able
to predict variation based on travel
time or Geographic distance let's think
about abiotic conditions the waxy gene
and these language families what we can
do when we have all these different
predictors that were interested in and
all these different snips these
different responses one approach that we
can use statistically as an ordination
approach called redundancy analysis this
is an approach where you have
multivariate predictors which could be
these different environmental variables
or language groups let's say and then
this multivariate response and then this
toy example this toy ordination of the
data you can see that we have with these
three snips two that are Co varying
across genotypes across land races let's
say so these are these are illegal
counts and so they're Co bearing
positively but not this third snip and
then if we look at these environmental
gradients we see that this temperature
gradient is also Co varying with that
changes in allele frequency as is this
precipitation gradient but not this
seasonality gradient so when we do our
coordination or redundancy analysis the
first axis which explains most of the
genetic variation separates a C and D
genotype that are identical at those two
snips from the a genotype with a B sort
of more intermediate and these
environmental gradients here show you
the loadings or how much of this genetic
divergence is explained by these two
different climate variables seasonality
is weakly related to that first axis so
that's how this ordination works and we
can apply this to these landrace data
with all these different explanatory
factors we can also ask how much of the
in this multivariate response is
explained by these different categories
so here's what I'm doing you I'm showing
you here from the redundancy analysis is
how much variation in the snips is
explained by these different categories
so these are oiler plots so that this
whole box represents all the stip
variation in japonica landraces that we
that we analyzed and then each of the
ellipsis represents the r-squared or or
how much variation is explained by these
different categories travel time or the
waxey mutation language group abiotic
emissions and the overlap between these
indicates that there's a lot of
collinearity there's a lot of
correlations between these explanatory
factors that we can't separate in its
contribution to explaining the snip
variation so lots of the snips the
biggest factor in both cases is this
geographic isolation or travel time
isolation that explains the biggest
portion of snip variation abiotic
conditions explain a pretty large
proportion of the variation japonica as
well but it's strongly overlap with
travel time meaning that two things that
are different in the abiotic environment
are also farther away in space and we
can't really figure out can't separate
out well how much of the variation is
due to that the wax mutation also is a
substantial contribution japonica but as
before I'll point out that not only with
the Geographic measures of isolation
which is a gray ellipses but these other
factors that we think may be important
those also have a lower explanatory
power for snip variation in indica than
in japonica so again in because lower
has less structure along these other
gradients besides this geographic region
also along abiotic gradients work
language groups for example now I want
to focus a little bit more on what
factors might be important amongst the
abiotic a variables this is for japonica
this is showing you the japonica
landraces that we analyzed and they're
colored according to nine different
genetic clusters so if we do this
redundancy analysis on those this first
axis which explains most of the snip
variation japonica about 12% of the
total snip variation this separates out
largely more temperate japonica from
more tropical japonica so these are
Northeast Asian and Southeast Asian and
then these vectors here show you the
environmental the climate variables well
there are a biotic they were soil
variables in there as well but these
climate variables come out as strongest
these are the
showing you those that are most strongly
associated with this accesses of genetic
divergence and those are things largely
associated with growing season
temperatures either growing season
warmth or variability or a lack of
predictability in growing season length
so what this is saying is that if we
take all the snip variation in japonica
the access that explains the most of it
is a gradient and temperature between
tropical and temperate japonica so
perhaps as temperature gradients explain
some of what we see for divergence
within japonica landraces
now we also looked a little bit further
here trying to look back into history to
try to understand the history of this
divergence so this is population genetic
demographic inference by Raphael
Goethe ker the postdoc I don't want you
so he first did cross coalescence to
estimate the split time between tropical
and temperate japonica and so he dates
it at about 3300 years ago with some air
around that going from about 4,000 to
2500 years ago and what's interesting
about this time frame is that it
corresponds to a major cooling period
known as that end of the mid Holstein
optimum so this is a period when and a
lot of the temperate asia conditions
cooled so working with working with
these archaeologists they did a climate
reconstruction of the suitability for
tropical japonica across the cultivated
traditional cultivated area of rice so
we think that in the original centre of
domestication the rice that was
originally domesticated was tropical
japonica like so adapted to tropical
conditions and if we look back this is
the start of the time series about 5,500
years ago this yellow indicates a high
suitability for tropical do ponic
meaning that temperatures were warm
enough to support a trip japonica
tropical japonica growing season in the
Yangtze Valley if we look back in that
time period as well this is mainly the
region where rice was found so rice
really hadn't spread out of that region
yet now if we look forward in time the
animation that that Kyle and Jade did
he's going to show you as temperatures
decline starting about 4,500 years ago
he stays east this region of East Asia
the Yangtze Valley cools down
substantially it becomes unsuitable for
tropical japonic so the growing season
length becomes much shorter and such
that it's not really good for tropical
japonica and this corresponds to the
time at which tropical Deepika and
temperature panic has split around 3,000
or so years ago right here and then
what's interesting with this period as
well is that it corresponds also to the
period in which rights movement in
Northeast Asia so that we're taking his
evidence that perhaps associated this
cooling event was adaptation of japonica
historically tropical land races through
temperate conditions which permitted
spread into Northeast Asia so that's
sort of our story that we draw from this
evidence that I'm showing you here ok so
to conclude that section we found that
this movement modeling of human movement
might be a way to try to get some better
understanding of gene flow patterns
across complex landscapes and then also
another major takeaway I'll give you is
that japonica seems to be much more
strongly structured now particularly
associated with growing season length
and growing season temperatures across
latitudes ok so I want to shift from
that sort of broad genome wide view of
variation among land races and to
thinking a little bit more about
specific genes or specific Llosa
involved in adaptation to different
environments and I'm gonna start this
section by making an observation which I
don't think you have to work too hard to
convince you of which is that doing
common gardens and phenotyping in the
field are very expensive and hard and so
this is sort of a traditional way that
we can learn about local adaptation to
different environments but it's not easy
so let's think about some other ways we
might be able to learn about genetic
variation that is locally adapted and
one of these approaches is to do what we
call gene environment associations with
search
similar in spirits here genotype
phenotype associations so if you collect
the rare successions sequence them
across the genome to get markers and
then calculate associations between
allelic state of these markers and the
environment which these things were
found in so in this case if this marker
these two different alleles don't seem
to be strongly structured along this
gradient but then we scan the genome and
we find some other locus
we're one allele is found and let's say
dry places the other allele is found in
wet places so this has become sort of a
easy-to-implement approach if you think
your system is locally adapted and you
have some idea about what might be
involved in those adaptation and we want
to sort of push this a little bit
farther though what we've started out
doing and this type of approach is
applying it to a biotic adaptation but
we could also have local adaptation to
biotic conditions or biotic partners and
so in sorghum which has traditionally
cultivated across much of sub-saharan
Africa and South Asia
it's very broadly distributed but within
certain regions of sub-saharan Africa it
faces parasitism from strata harmonica
which is a really major problem it's a
root parasite that reduces yields it can
even kill host plants but notice
distribution of the parasite is narrower
than the host so it could be that the
host has some mechanisms by which it
locally adapted to these regions either
mechanisms of resistance to the parasite
or tolerance so when I explore this
question so when I point out that
instead of some abiotic gradient
underlying local adaptation you could
have changes in the biotic partners in
the environment now a little bit of
biology on the system that will frame
some of our investigation of diversity
here we think that strategy lactones
play a really important part in the host
parasite relationship here the strangle
act tones are hormones plant hormones
and they're released into soil they're
exerted firm roots parasitic plants have
seeds that are sitting out here in the
soil waiting for these drag lactone
signals when they sense the struggle act
owns they germinate and grow into the
roots and infect the roots and take what
they need and then they reproduce so
this is a host parasite relationship
that benefits the parasitic plant the
signaling is initiated with straggle
actions what's interesting about strong
lactone signaling is it's also an early
stage in signaling from host plants too
much microbial fungi so this could be a
mutualistic relationship here that
trades off against the parasitic
relationship depending on what your
strategy is for struggle act on
excitation so we're going to investigate
strangle act on the best excitation here
and in particular we're going to start
by looking at diversity at this
particular gene so this is the first
gene in sorghum that was identified as
probably being a mechanism of resistance
to strata this is it this is these are
results from the j2 lab at Purdue and
this is the product of a few different
pieces of information starting with a by
parental cross that narrow this down to
a QTL for resistance and then some fine
mapping and then some complementary
pieces of information that made them
think that this is probably the gene but
basically here this is showing you
images of the susceptible and resistant
genotypes so here's a sorghum root in
gel and these are all these different
strata seeds and you can see them
germinating whereas in this resistant or
this putative resistant phenotype the
strongest seeds are not germinating and
the authors show that this corresponds
to a change in the major type of
struggle actin is suited from five G oxy
straggle to or a bank halt which seems
to not stimulate germination of these
parasites now this was identified from a
by parental cross and it was identified
in a series of experiments that were
done in a fairly small number of sites
and also mostly in the lab so one
question when you see a result like this
or when you obtain a result like this
yourself you might have is how durable
is this mechanism of resistance across
environments and across hosts heracross
genetic backgrounds stronger Monica's in
West Africa is in East Africa very
broadly distributed and there it could
be that there are negative interactions
between this resistance allele and
different genetic backgrounds so that's
not always useful or in certain
environments so wanted to do was
investigate diversity at this locus now
we have a problem though which is we
have all these Landry so I'm not showing
you the land races here but we had all
these land race collection points so we
know land races are from individual
points across the landscape then we also
had occurrence points where we knew the
parasite had been detected mostly from
museum specimens but also from some
botanical literature but we needed to do
is to have some quantitative estimate of
parasite pressure or parasite prevalence
in any individual location where land
race was collected so what we did just
work by Emily Bell's who was a postdoc
in my lab has now started a lab at
Arkansas State just recently she fitted
a model that relates the suitability for
strata
underlying environmental conditions so
when you fit this model using these
occurrences what you can then do is say
for any point on the landscape
what's the suitability for strata or
what's the likely pressure from strata
that might select for resistance or
tolerance on sorghum and then we wanted
to do was to look at variation at this
resistance illegal across the big
diversity panel that we had sheet a time
by sequencing for but the problem we
have is that this gene here which was
computed Li the resistance gene the
resistance alleles are large deletions
so here's one of them and here's an
additional large deletion so these large
deletion legals are not really that well
characterized in the GPS data are hard
to characterize in the GPS data because
you don't always know if you're just
missing coverage in certain regions or
if indeed there is a large deletion
there so what Emily did was take the
receipt when Singh data and characterize
these deletions and then look at the
genotype my sequencing data if there are
accessions
of sorghum or landraces where we have
snip calls adjacent to the deletions but
missing from within we call those as
actual delecious where in 2000 sexual
deletions and then we also found from
this receipt letting data an additional
variant of unknown function which is a
frameshift
early in the that's in these first exon
of this LGS one gene so we don't really
know what the functional effect of this
is that we're following up on it and
I'll show you some results from it here
in a second so the first thing to note
is that these large deletions that are
puted with the resistance alleles are
actually associated with the occurrence
of strata so all the symbols on this map
are sorghum landraces and the underlying
surface there is the expected
probability that strata will occur or
the habitat suitability for strata
harmonica so these X's are the large
deletions and you see those X's tend to
occur in regions of high parasite
suitability mostly this belt in West
Africa here this region in Sudan you can
make a density plot here along a
gradient of habitat suitability density
of these different alleles and you can
see that the two deletion alleles shown
in red and / / sorry blue and purple
here are more common where the parasite
is more common so that suggests they are
beneficial where the parasite is a major
I'm not showing you data on it but
they're also common and distributed
across different genetic backgrounds so
that suggests they may be useful in
multiple genetic backgrounds we also
also note that this frameshift has a
distribution that sort of fits with the
distribution the parasite although it's
not as closely linked so that's this red
density curve here is the distribution
of that frameshift we're not really sure
what the functional impact or potential
importance of that is but that's
something we're following up now I want
to sort of get back to this question of
trade-offs is there a trade-off
associated with this mechanism of
resistance now give you that hypothesis
early on that because struggle AK tones
are used in signaling with mycorrhizae
fungi if you change struggle AK tones to
avoid the parasite you may compare your
ability to form my Creswell associations
that's one way to think there might be a
trade off the authors suggest that
there's there's maybe perhaps no
negative productivity side effects of
this resistance mechanism but I'm sort
of just generally a skeptic the authors
did do do assays of micro cell
colonization of the resistant in black
and susceptible parental genotypes in
grey there's some in some of these
strains there's some suggestion of lower
mike rizzo colonization but it's not
really very clear so there's least not a
strong impairment mike rizzo so
association in these three lab strains
of micro fungi but we wanted to sort of
approach this in a little bit different
of a way because we've see evidence for
a trade off when we look at these
geographic distributions if you look
there's this region sort of along the
northern area a drier edge of what is
cult about that it's cultivated where
there are traditional sorghum varieties
landraces but the parasite does not
really make it and the resistance
alleles don't really make it into those
regions as well especially the elysion
alleles don't get into these wetter
regions as well you can sort of just see
this we just plot out this is the same
Platt from before except I've just
aggregating the deletions the fact that
the deletions become rarer despite the
opportunity for gene flow where the
parasite is not present that suggests
something is limiting them from
increasing in frequency on top of that
it might not be a parent but these
deletion alleles never really get to
very high frequencies so these gray
circles are all the other alleles that
just look like the
deleted or non frameshift alleles there
are lots of those landraces there and
actually the deletions never even in
this region get higher than 15 to 20
percent frequency uplander East's so it
seems like something is constraining
their rise and frequency it could be
there's a trade-off it could be that
there is frequency dependent selection
sort of this putative resistant allele
starts to dominate the landscape
parasites adapt and we have we have good
reason to think that's actually a
possibility here another thing that
we've done to try to investigate this
question of potential trade-offs because
we see this distributional evidence to
suggest something's constraining the
distribution of the resistance allele
what we've done also and we're
continuing this work is looking at
transcriptomes of these different
genotypes that differ this resistance
allele because the idea is that the
transcriptome has many traits that is
characterizing so that may give us an
idea of what other traits might be
affected because we're talking about
playing hormones right so these things
should be very pleiotropic so what we
did sign is with in the root
transcriptomes of the sorghum in tact
versus deletion or susceptible versus
resistant lines we see a few different
genes that are upregulated in the
resistant line in the biosynthetic
pathway you don't have to follow the
details of this biosynthetic pathway but
the whole biosynthetic pathway is
changing in this resistant line despite
the fact that the change in struggle AK
tones should only be occurring at the
end of this so it could be that there's
greater synthesis of bios of straight
electrons going on there may be higher
struggle actin levels in there putative
for system whine which is a little
confusing but I'll just sort of leave
that at there we're following up on that
but related to this question of whether
strata might be able to adapt to this
resistance allele we've seen some
helpful results using some CRISPR
deletion mutants that we were able to
obtain recently from court Ava
so people Cortana we're on Gao
especially got interested in this system
and made deletion alleles that replicate
the natural resistant alleles for LG s1
this dragon resistance locust so the one
thing that we see from these deletion
alleles is that indeed they are the gene
that causes the low germination
stimulation at this QTL
so if you look here I'm showing you
three different environmental treatments
two different strata populations and
then the germination of strata seeds so
the deletion allele the puter
that one it is universally inducing less
germination okay so that suggests that
there is this is actually the gene
that's causing resistance at this QTL
but one thing I want to point out is
that resistance has varying levels of
success depending on the abiotic
treatment or the population of strata
that you're using so this key boughs
population from around Lake Victoria in
Kenya has modest germination reasonably
high germination I'd say even against
these recipient of resistant genotypes
of sorghum so I think that's a lesson
that that perhaps there is no free lunch
associated with this resistance allele
but it is encouraging because well the
general message is encouraging because
we do have this thing being to a certain
degree broadly distributed across
Raggett prone regions this is just a
picture of some of our experiments with
germinating Strega seeds okay now one
other thing that we're able to do with
Emily's work here is take that fitted
surface of strata prevalence and employ
this environmental Association analysis
so she can scan the sorghum genome now
and find low Tsai where you have a
strong association between allele
frequency and the prevalence of strata
harmonica as estimated from the
distribution model and we have some
candidate low side that are that are
colored here here's one involved in
struggle act on signaling I'm not gonna
focus on it too much here's a high
frequency snip in a pectin esterase
which also shows a peak into GSD
population genetic statistic suggesting
balancing selection at that locus and
here's the distribution of that snip in
that pectin s trace now you can see it
fits pretty well the distribution of the
parasite which is why I popped down on
the scan and I'll just briefly mention
that we think pectin s raised to play a
role because when parasites are invading
the roots there's some chain changes in
cell walls of the host that they're
affecting so there could be some
corresponding mechanisms of resistance
in the host so just to conclude that
section we see some evidence that this
resistant allele is actually effective
across backgrounds and environments but
with some constraints perhaps and that
we may be able to use this kind of
approach to find new low-side that cause
local adaptation to this parasite in
this case
okay so the last part of this talk I
want to give you a brief description of
a way we've tried to apply some of these
associations with underlying environment
to perhaps make predictions that could
be useful and under some setting this is
with the rabbitov says I want to start
with the sort of premise that if we are
really capturing some genetic signature
of local adaptation and we should be
able to make some predictions about
trade-offs because those are the
definition and the heart of local
adaptation right and what we're going to
do specifically with rabid offices we're
gonna try to predict changes in Fitness
long environmental gradients so we're
gonna take diverse accessions of a rabid
OPS's that have been sequenced at many
markers fit a model that relates how
cold it gets in the winter so we think
this is an important selective gradient
underlying those adaptation in
Arabidopsis we fit that model and then
out-of-sample we're gonna develop
predictions of that model for what we
might call the optimal environmental the
optimal winter temperature of these
different accessions of rabid OPS's so
in this case here's these two alleles
here might correspond to a warm
environment if we see a genotype and our
prediction set that has those alleles we
might predict there will be relatively
more fit under warmer environments and
vice-versa the dataset that we're going
to use for this are from a few published
studies from a few years ago on
Arabidopsis so this is a one paper where
they took about a thousand natural lines
and used a snip array to characterize
about 200,000 snips across the genome
and then any schmitz lab conducted for
different common gardens across europe
and pretty different climates and
measured Fitness in the field of these
rabid OPS's genotypes so but we have
total from the data here that we're
using are all these things that are
sequenced in gray we don't actually have
those things represented in the common
Gardens blue ones are the only ones
there in the common gardens but these
gray ones we do know the winter
environment they're from so they may be
useful in the fitting of this model or
we're relating genotype to underlying
environment
we're gonna do here is a genomic
selection type approach where we're
going to fit a relationship with home
minimum winter temperatures of these
genotypes that and so these these this
visit these models have correlated
random effects that have a correlation
structure that is determined by this
kinship matrix so essentially this is
this is saying genome-wide similarity
can correspond to genome wat and in
genotype can correspond to genotype
similarity and home environment so we're
gonna fit that and here's the underlying
gradient of minimum winter temperature
just you get a sense for that so then we
we fit that model and then we do
cross-validation and make out-of-sample
predictions of what I've been calling a
latent cold adapted phenotype so the
idea is that we're fitting a model that
relates this home winter environment to
GSA and we don't really know what the
phenotype necessarily is that underlies
adaptation to that specific environment
and its really something
multi-dimensional right for that reason
I'm just calling it a latent cold
adapted phenotype so we don't really
know what it is another way to think of
it it's really what I'm showing you here
are the predicted minimum temperatures
so the G Bluffs for the predicted Oh
minimum temperatures of these egos so if
we look at the variation in these
predictions among genotypes and then
look at the relative fitness and Finland
we see that and we can fit a quadratic
and see there's some optimal value for
relative fitness that is fairly low in
terms of the winter minimum temperature
environment that we predict that has the
highest relative fitness then we can
look at how that corresponds like how
that changes across these four different
common gardens and you can see for the
UK so here's how to show you the results
specifically from the UK here this is
from Norwich where it doesn't really get
that cold military the latent
cold-adapted phenotype or the predicted
winter cold environment of these
different eco types that had the highest
relative fitness was the maximum one so
there seemed to be no value for having
these colder winter home genetic
signatures in the UK and the same was
true for the Spanish site so here I'm
now showing you the actual temperature
of the common garden so how was the
climate at that location
here's Finland Germany UK Spain and then
which of these predicted phenotypes or
these winter cold predictions for these
different genotypes had the highest
maximum Fitness from these curves so you
can see in Finland pretty cold genotype
had the highest Fitness in Germany is
intermediate and then in the UK and
Spain and increases so just fitting this
model of genotype to home environment
we're able to do some prediction
out-of-sample for changes in relative
fitness across the gradient so perhaps
there's some value to that in
conservation or perhaps if we're
interested in breeding things for
specific environments so just to
summarize the three parts today I think
there's some evidence the local
adaptation is important in cropland
races and an important factor select
shaping genetic variation across the
genome I think that there's some
evidence we maybe can use genome
environment associations to find new low
SIA that cause local adaptation in land
races or other systems and that these
these environmental associations may
also have some value for predicting
genotype environment interactions so
with that I want to thank co-authors
from the rice project I didn't mention
some other co-authors from the strata
project and funding sources for some of
the work thank you in any of this can
you say anything about this okay so I
guess there's a lot of connections none
of these are polyploid there's a lot of
connections I guess you could draw
people have maybe suppose that some
polyploid ZAR are more plastic and
perhaps in that case maybe less closely
locally adapted to their environments
and maybe more of a Mormon environmental
generalists well there's no there's
there's a hypothesis for the
clarification there yeah I haven't
worked any polyploid systems I have to
admit and I haven't well we actually are
working in switchgrass now and what we
sort of were fairly early in the project
and I need to think harder about it to
have some more insightful thing to say
sorry
travel distance have you considered
things like currents and winds or video
just use those yeah so we haven't
considered some of the heterogeneity and
you might have over the ocean like
currents or winds
that's what EMA is the archaeologist
sort of specializes in and so she's
working now and trying to do some of
that for like a next generation of this
this is sort of a first stab at it so
you and you said you don't really know
what it is so you said this is just
forget what very well you've got one
variable to substitute in for that late
do you have approaches to do to try to
piece together what the latent variable
might look like from a multivariate
observed feed it's like perspective yeah
yeah so so just to be clear here what
I'm what I'm doing is I'm picking an
environmental gradient that I think is
important in local adaptation which is
how cold does it get in the winter and
there is evidence that that is an
important selective gradient on your
house it's independent of this now then
what I'm saying is if they are adapted
along this gradient there's some
multi-dimensional phenotype behind that
but I don't know what it is but here I'm
just fitting a model for home and winter
temperature and they're not making
predictions out-of-sample for home
winter temperature but they're you know
I'm not so you know the prediction is
like what would be your environmental
home if if you know you had if you were
from the you know if you were natural
genius F these are all natural genotypes
but you could do this for breeding lines
you know things there add mixtures and
make predictions about like what would
be your home environment based on your
genomic signature that's the flavor
that's what we're doing another way I
sort of try to think of it as there's
this latent multi-dimensional phenotype
now you could go to high dimensional
phenotype data and ask what corresponds
this variation so transcriptome data or
you know with model system we've got
lots of experiments lots of phenotypes
from different situations where you
could you know sort of mine the data for
the phenotypes that are associated with
this genetic variation
I might be with something yeah when
working with the sentimental she was
association how do you make sure
important I won't be the best way of
making sure that you're not explaining
the population structure that might be
highly correlated yeah so I think that
sort of depends on the goal in the case
where we're like scanning the genome and
trying to identify an individual loci
that are you know single locus effects
on local adaptation what we do is we
essentially control for the genetic
background just as you do in association
models with a random effects that are
correlated according to the genome-wide
similarity is your genotypes in this
case I'm not so much worried about
identifying an individual locus so I'm
actually just using that whole
genome-wide signature of variation among
genotypes to make to predict differences
in this trade or trade in quotes yeah so
one of your systems is one involving
natural distributions of myosin two of
them involved land races and cultivate
redness and of course in the rabid
abscess discussion you didn't talk about
language groups or human migration
patterns all I'm just wondering if there
are any emergent properties of these two
kinds of systems that are beginning to
be recognizable must be different
aspects of how the genotypes are coming
so some generalities about differences
between these cultivated and natural
systems one thing that one thing that's
pretty it's maybe not that interesting
but one thing that that has shown up is
that the structuring along and these
environmental gradients is much stronger
from the cropland races so so more of
the genome course is correlated with the
environmental gradients in the land
races than it is in rabid OPS's
so that could be because you know these
crops have much more recently spread
across these gradients so there's been a
lot more of the genome that's been
carried along with locally adaptive
variation such that you have lots more
structure along environmental gradients
in the land races you know they're
talking about a few thousand years
versus tens of thousands or more during
the glaciation you know at least so
there's a whole long set of demography
anyway so I'm not going to get into all
that for a rabid abscess but that's sort
of one contrast I mean the the case for
these land races may be sort of more
similar to what we see in invasive
populations much more recently
established populations that
nevertheless become locally adapted
including rabid offices has locally
adapted it seems populations in North
America that are non-native we're about
to start a pretty extensive project on
cheatgrass out west which is only been
out west for a hundred years or so but
has pretty clearly locally adapted
across the landscape and that maybe a
more similar pattern at least in terms
of large portions of the genome being
varying along these gradients and it
becomes a little tricky to sort of
retrospectively figure out what's
driving local adaptation when such large
portions of the genome are Co varying
perhaps for spurious reasons of limited
gene flow so maybe harder to do in these
Landry systems than in natural systems
where there's been more gene flow across
gradients I feel like maybe I'm starting
to ramble yeah sorry I wish I had
something well so so one thing that's
kind of one thing I'll say that I've
become interested in is you know it's
been easy for us to do these analysis
using climate gradients cuz you just go
and download some climate data set but
that doesn't really mean that's like the
best way to characterize a selectively
the selection at an individual location
and of course in the agricultural
context you could have differences and
agronomy differences in management or
different purposes things are being
selected for forage versus cranes etc
that's sort of one complexity that it
may interact with these a large scale
abiotic ratings that are easily download
data for that's much harder to
characterize this local small
scale stuff someone really first rabid
offices they occur across a pretty wide
range of microhabitats early
successional sandy beaches rocky have
rocky outcrops agricultural fields and
so what these environmental conditions
mean in those different contexts is not
the same thing just like in the
agricultural thing agricultural systems
where different agronomy czar usage
purposes may mean that a given abiotic
stressor doesn't mean the same thing for
these different local contexts so that
that's a sort of frontier to sort of
what we're trying to do go for going
forward stuff yeah one thing I didn't
really talk about much here that has
sort of been something I think about a
lot I'm not sure reviewers have never
really pointed to it and said oh that's
great so I don't really know how much
anyone cares about it but in all these
systems we've been trying to model
growing seasons to get a better picture
of what are likely select ingredients
because you know anything that has some
phenology where it's dormant for part of
the year either as a seed or as a stay a
perennial that drops us leaves
that's deciduous it you know the
conditions at a given time of year are
much more important if you have
sensitive vegetative or reproductive
tissue that's out there right so that's
why we've been trying to build a growing
season models or just work with existing
growing season models to characterize
conditions during growing seasons that's
perhaps some more accurate measures of
selective pressures at a given location
and it is important especially for
things like moisture and rapid abscess
you know these rapid offsets ecotypes
from mediterranean often have pretty
fast life cycles in these winter
actually often fairly wet growing
seasons it does rain in the wintertime
they'll start you know in January and
February and it's actually not that dry
that they're not out there growing in
the middle of the summer when the rains
stopped so those things are important
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu